c'est assez compliqué au début pour
apprendre pour freiner parce qu'il faut
freiner avec les pieds au lieu qu'avec
les mains hermès 13 ans adepte du vtt a
pu tester pour la première fois la piste
du vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
il était accompagné de sa classe de 4e
du collège de la couldre de montigny le
bretonneux
cette session a été organisée ce
mercredi 14 décembre dans le cadre des
deux pays
les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire l'idée c'est de
pouvoir justement répondre cette action
donc à l'ensemble des institutions
scolaires de la région ile de france est
donc là on poursuit respect devant la
série 2-2 d'opération avec avec les
collèges
donc ce n'est pas la première
aujourd'hui et ce ne sera pas la
dernière non plus après un baptême d'une
heure les 30 élèves avaient le sourire
c'est très bien même si j'ai vu quelques
chutes du mois tu as retrouvé les sinon
ça rester cool la matinée s'est ensuite
poursuivie par un entraînement de
l'équipe de france à la fin de la
session
les collégiens ont pu poser des
questions aux pistards bah ouais ça
vraiment sympa de pouvoir partager notre
passion avec avec ces collégiens la
piste c'est pas très connu du coup bah
ça me fait plaisir de leur faire
connaître un peu ce monde ce parti-là du
vélo qui est pas connu du tout je me dis
qu'ils sont hyper fort et ceux des
professionnels
enfin il roule hyper vite et tout fin
paravent à ce que j'ai fait moi je me
dis que c'est vraiment incroyable ce
qu'ils font est tout au total près de
300 jeunes ont participé à ces deux pays
au vélodrome depuis deux ans de
nouvelles sessions avec les collégiens
devraient être organisées au premier
trimestre 2010 7